for price it is his tenth start this
season against philadelphia on wednesday
he goes four innings and you just look
at that and it's like well he didn't
give you much but you dig a little
deeper and it was quite an impressive
thing that he did two innings and then
almost an hour delay but he said i'm
going back out there
base is empty for brian reynolds
home of the 1-2 and a bouncing ball to
short takes a nice bounce for corey
seeger and price has a clean first
inning take a uh
look at will crow's numbers they're
brought to you by the pennsylvania
lottery turner who's been one of the
best two strike hitters in baseball this
year both hits last night came with two
strikes
fell behind o2 now a 3-2 and another
two-strike hit for turner this one for
extra bases
it's a lead-off double for trey turner
to try and get
pollock here
and get a chase from him
and get out of this jam
he gets the chase
and the strikeout
runners up the second and third two out
the two out chance for trey turner
and a swinging a fly ball to right but
right at polanco he never moves his feet
and makes the catch to end the inning
here's the newly mustachioed bengal
featuring the fu manchu
and line drive and over the head and
taylor who goes into the wall hard
and gamble's going to wind up at third
base
with a
stand-up triple and
the dodgers have to be very concerned
about taylor's condition he just
he's looking not in his head i'm all
right but wow he never
shied away from
that wall whatsoever
thank goodness they're all padded
nowadays
and he didn't slow down they just gave
everything and
crashed hard into it
oh man oh side of his head right into
everything shoulder
third two gone back to the top and kevin
newman
lifts this one to right center taylor on
the move will get there this time and
that's the ending
price pitches around the one out triple
second and third one gone for pollock
struck out his first time
here he hits one into center field and
they'll finally break the seal
seeger and bellinger headed home two run
single legs they pilot and they break
through here in the third
[Applause]
well two balls
actually all three balls so far in this
inning weren't hit really hard right on
the barrel we got corey seeger gets
jammed a little bit goes the other way
gets a double cody ballinger gets one
off the end of the back gets a double
hustling double and then now we see aj
pollock that ball gets in in on him
strong enough fights it off single
scores two runs
put the ball in play excellent job
dodgers get rewarded ryan reynolds will
try his hand bounced out to short his
only time
lines this toward left center field he
jumped on that fastball from david price
he brian hayes gonna be waved home by
joey cora and there will be no throw
it's an rbi double
for key brian hayes and a 2-1 ball game
for
reynolds driving in hayes
72 ribbies for brian reynolds
the dodgers will bring the infield up
with one out
here's stallings
price ready here it is swinging the
ground ball to third a couple of hops
toward locks the throw to the plate and
missed by smith it bangs off the home
plate umpire's foot and goes to the back
stop and stallings will assume second
the tying run across and the pirates
have nodded it at two
i i love aggressive base running i i
love the aggressive decision making
by
derrick shelton there i told you i mean
they're in the grass they are in the
grass because they don't want
you going on a ball on the ground and
the ball wasn't crushed
and
i say this a lot anytime an infielder
has to go to his left a right-handed
hidden fielder has to go to his left
it's a difficult play so a two-out
chance for baby
another 2-2
ground ball base hit past the diving
suit sugo
brady puts the dodgers back in front one
run is in here comes he'll score
[Applause]
[Music]
it's 4-2 in the fifth
great job by matt badie good at bat he's
laid off some tough pitches once he got
two strikes on him he's fouled off some
pitches and they get the pitch he can
handle
hits it right down the line great aim
great placement
the bullpen perfect so far tonight seven
up and seven down blake trynan tries to
keep that going over the last 10 games a
126 era for this group
goes around in trinidad with the
strikeouts open his night
stays there and watches it fly by
back-to-back case to open the eighth for
trident here's brian reynolds knocked in
a run scored a run in the two-run third
or the two run fourth for the pirates
here first pitch swinging muncie beats
him to the bag
and ends the innings over the ninth
inning we go with the dodgers up 4-2
perfect relief so far tonight
10 up 10 down kenley janssen looking for
the last three outs
looking to continue that the bullpen has
been outstanding every single guy coming
out of the
out that door has been pounding the
strike zone attacking the hitters now
with a two-run lead
it's up to your closer to continue to do
that
two on just the one out moran up there
pinch hitting broken back little flair
gonna drop
sotsugo scores
it's a one-run ball game
pirate fans liking it
4-3 they had to shake things up there a
little bit say hey guys let's go
that down and in pitch didn't really
drop the head that on it drive it
anywhere but i'll take it just one more
like that away from tying this baby up
and now it's hoy park last chance for
the pirates
ground ball right side trey turner's
there that does it they hang on for
three
to win their ninth out of their last ten
and to keep pace with the giants
once again the dodgers pitching step
really kept them in this ball game yeah
you're thinking you see those three runs
but the bullpen coming in getting the
job done
retiring the first 10 batters that they
had faced as well
it's just a good win all around